here The Situation's we're going to have
a look at today okay now just to review
before we get on to circles and
invariably people sitting around tables
let's think about how we normally do
regions
so we're thinking of things like this
okay and you think of you know arranging
letters in a word or arranging people in
a lie or putting people into teams or
you get the idea okay so thinking about
something like with the government
Regents we're thinking about not just
not just combinations but wanted to know
okay you know two people sitting in
relation to each other in different
orders there is manner okay as anyone
who has sat around a full table will
attest to so this is permutations and
okay when you see this this is about
permutations so get your head back into
that space right now let's think about
just normal permutations in a why right
if you've got four objects you want to
put them into four places okay what was
the way that we worked out no
replacement like we actually put real
objects that can't be repeated how many
ways are there to get something for the
first spot answer four ways cuz you got
four things right and then you got three
more people left to put into the next
spot and then two and then one right so
this is where we've got our factorial
sort of rotation okay now when you have
a look at a situation like this okay it
looks so similar you've still got four
things four people and you've still got
four places to put them into okay but
there's a problem
well think about like this let's let's
proceed the way we did before pick chair
any chair let's say this one how many
people can we put into this chair there
are four people I can put into this
chair right and then you keep going
around just like you went this way
you're like well I can put three more
people into that chair and then
two left and then whoever's last through
the table gets to sit in that spot right
so on the face of it it looks like it's
saved okay except the problem is right
we care about order here we care about
order here okay and the problem with
this is that well just like with the
permutation combinations we're looking
at before a whole bunch of the
arrangements you'll come up with will
really actually be the same okay example
if you're four people have you know
really imaginative names like say okay
right I just had to look at make sure
you all start with different okay
there's one arrangement right there was
my um you know first spots have ended
got him first then joong-gu I'm put in
second that Martin was the last of the
table okay
what if for instance submit there was
first but he he decided actually he
likes this table up sorry this chair up
here right and then jr. still wanted to
sit next to her and then Martin was
still left over here these arrangements
are the same they're still the same
arrangements I'm just looking at it from
a different angle right just like you
know if I showed you this
okay and said you look from this angle
or look from that angle like well the
only difference between these two things
is which side to standing on all I had
to do is rotate okay here's the question
how many of these am I going to have how
many extras have I come up with the
answer is I'll have four times as many
as I should
I'll have three extras right because I
can rotate this once and then twice and
then three times when I take the fourth
time I'll literally be back to here okay
so I have four times too many okay so
instead of 4 factorial what I really
have is 4 factorial on 4 right and that
4 comes from the fact that I've got 4
spots and for people to put in those
spots so in fact for an arrangement like
this rather than in factorial right if
you want to generalize you know let's
see that much pointing to you the
general thing for this is well this is n
minus 1 factorial simple if you had 12
people to see them around an agent
banquet table and they would be minus 1
11 factorial ways to arrange them make
sense ok now one more way to think about
it okay you can think about it in these
terms that you're you're doing this kind
of setup but then you're over counting
right so you correct by dividing and
that's what you end up with the
alternative which is a way I like to
think about it because it fits into how
we think that conditions and all that
kind of thing is you think about the
circle as a condition and you know when
we look at our agents of probability you
always deal with conditions first they
change your sample space or whatever and
then you let the situation unfold so
here's the way I would pick it ok when
you think about that first person I
think it was something okay
you think of that that first person
really all of these chairs are identical
they don't actually have any differences
between them okay because if we sit in
here we just rotate the table and he's
at another's chair well it's the same
thing okay so here's the approach I have
you take your first person and you just
lock them in place you lock them in
place okay
now you don't worry about where they're
going to sit because all the other
places are the same to them okay now
what are you going to do we have three
things to fill and you have three
objects to fill them with at unlike this
situation you can't rotate these right
this is a line like this right it's just
that well there's only three spots these
are n minus one okay so your first
person you just lock him in and then
there are three to one ways to arrange
what's left three factorial
there's any sense